are you doing doing good
you were saying you've been watching The
Sopranos well I just saw you busting out
your Henry Hill shirt there can't go
wrong and over I thought it was the
Sopranos you know I mean I went back
because obviously I was sitting on set
and you just need something good to
watch and to have a laugh and just
youtube your favorite scene or scenes
from The Sopranos I so I can't Google a
couple of those wooden because I love
watching olivine you yeah it's what we
call a good show it's what we could yeah
I mean oh you know probably the best
before we get started I have to just
tangent and say congrats on being part
of the movie that will probably have the
most bonkers ending of the year they're
much serenity about a million movies and
I did not see that ending cut you know I
haven't seen the ending oh I haven't
seen the final calm okay well I'm gonna
let you know it has a very unique and
I'm all for stuff like that swing big
and go Lord yeah I think so too I mean I
you know I didn't read all the criticism
wasn't a holiday in Australia and and I
was a bit surprised though you know
hearing beggars it's like you know what
I get it but like Stephen Knight tried
to do something did work maybe not Betty
Greenway tried it is a cycle if we've
become so mainline you know that we can
examine a Marvel movie as if it's you
know Dostoyevsky
but somebody trying something that
doesn't work we've really got a jump all
over it and grind it into the dirt see I
don't have a pro I actually think the
ending does work I think it's just so
people are not used to things swinging
for the fences does it not no and there
you know what I mean it ya know I know I
know I know I know I personally was all
in because again I have not seen
anything like it
yeah you know I agree you know I need
filmmakers like that you know and it's a
taking unique individual to to throw
that down completely jumping into why I
get to talk to you great uh Congrats on
this movie thank you it is still
interesting because this is a time that
I was not familiar with another history
buff yeah yeah I would imagine the same
must have applied for you that yes this
takes place I know
movies and television don't cover these
moments in his no they don't know which
is why I loved it yeah it's true which i
think is why you know Ridley Scott at
the starter which is right everyone
involved love did it it's that window
you know at the end of World War two
everything the war's over let's go home
and get on with our lives and we go
under the you know post-industrial
America and things kick off but you know
yeah Europe's a mess you know it's the
neighbors have been slaughtering each
other has been genocide and you know
they were starving and and somebody had
to you know you had to put Germany and
Japan back on its feet as well as your
own country which we informed and Lewis
is one of those men that that was
responsible for that you know for
putting them back together so they could
function as a society and end up you
know you think we're we now 60 years
later what we Germany is a powerhouse
leading the way in Europe
Bliley uh when you are getting ready for
a role like this which is not like a
physical role it's more about it's
nuanced it's a moat trying to show
emotion and feelings on your face yeah
is it sort of how how do you prepare for
something like that or is it is it sort
of like you put the costume on and it
just all of a sudden happens but in the
cost you want does help I mean really in
a military where is you know it's
buttoned down
no it's it and and also he's a man
responsible for so many people but I
mean it was it's like he said the
research I did a lot of reading about
you know the end of Germany the fall you
know beavers book the fall of Berlin and
some picture books on Hamburg and you
know but just that that end that that
what state Germany was in that that that
Lewis was bringing his wife into when
she gets off that train he's brought her
into hell you know I mean which is rough
on a woman rough on anybody you know let
alone somebody know that's been out the
country lost a child so it's things like
that then you know you trust your
director you know that really you don't
need to go overboard and be you know you
let the audience into your your heart
and your soul and if you watched our
Anthony Hopkins in you know pays the
parlor Oh what remains of the deck
remains
you know one of them one of the great
restraint but your heart breaks you know
people come in to it allow them to feel
you know that that that that their love
all three of them I guess is real you
know and it's all valid in its own way
and particularly in you know in
supporting Kyra's character Rachel in
terms of understanding that our heart is
valid and that she's not one thing for
running off with another man you know
and she don't think we're just coming
back to Lewis and putting up with you
know it's it's that is the way that love
can play out we think that some things
are unforgivable but you know what when
you've been through a wall like that or
when you when you really love something
what is unforgivable what's more
important usually it's it's it's it's
the person you love and for Lewis that
was it for him
you know completely
you